india's prime minister narendra modi is
in berlin today where he's a meeting
with german chancellor olaf schutz while
the focus of modi's visit is on trade
and energy partnerships the war in
ukraine is overshadowing the meeting
india which imports much of its military
hardware from russia is trying to walk a
diplomatic tightrope between moscow and
the west modi has so far refused to
condemn the russian invasion or to
impose sanctions on russia straining
india's relationship with the eu
minister of india days ago in delhi
prime minister narendra modi opens
india's flagship global forum the
reizina dialogue
guest of honor ozola fonda line
president of the european commission her
message europe and india must grow
closer together
for the european union strengthening
and energizing
its partnership with india is a priority
in this upcoming decade and therefore i
am very pleased that today prime
minister modi and i have agreed to
establish an eu india trade and
technology council to tackle
key trade economic and technological
challenges
but the war raging thousands of
kilometers away in ukraine is casting a
shadow on europe's ties with india
prime minister narendra modi has not
condemned the russian invasion he's
trying not to risk india's traditionally
close ties with russia
vonderlein spoke emotionally of her own
visit to ukraine where she witnessed the
mass graves of butcher and she insisted
that india could not look away
the outcome of the war
will not only determine the future of
europe
but also deeply affect
the indo-pacific region and the rest of
the world
for the indo-pacific region it is as
important as for europe
that borders are respected
and that spheres of influence are
rejected
but for india's foreign minister some of
this message rings hollow
we've been hearing for the last two
months a lot of our lot of arguments
from europe saying you know that things
happening in europe and asia should
worry about it because these could
happen in asia
guess what things have been happening in
asia for the last 10 years
a prime example for indian critics of
europe the chaotic western withdrawal
last year from afghanistan raising
questions over the west's commitment to
the region into its values
now let's bring in dw's chief
international editor richard walker is
here in berlin ntw correspondent monira
chowdhury in delhi uh richard let's
start with you how is schultz trying to
bind india closer to the west
yeah well gerhard we saw some examples
of what's going on in the relationship
between europe as a whole and india uh
uh in the report just there uh from
delhi last week with ursula fonda line
announcing this big tech and trade
council uh uh to to boost uh uh to boost
uh kind of discussions between the two
sides coordinate coordination between
the two sides on the crucial areas of
technology and trade in the ways that
they intersect and you have similar kind
of discussions going on here with
germany also setting up various
different types of agreements to try to
increase the engagement with india
because what you have here
in germany and europe as a whole is a
recognition of the importance of india a
growing recognition of the importance of
india strategically in the region being
discussed as the indo-pacific these days
not so much asia pacific but with india
very much in the heart of that
and that is not just because india is
rising it's been rising for years but
it's also because of a growing
recognition of the challenge that china
is presenting across that region and the
sense that trying to bind india closer
to the west is a crucial way of trying
to stand up to that challenge
let's go to manira in delhi there manira
how do people in india react to the the
war in ukraine what's public opinion
like is it behind modi and its policies
well when it comes to the diplomatic
response of india we all know what it's
been like over the past uh two months
since the invasion began the the
diplomatic response by the indian
government has also evolved but is still
far away from openly condemning the
invasion when it comes internally to the
public to the public opinion well there
are both sides there are both sets of
people there both sets of responses
there are those people who are
supporting russia who are saying well
what's happening with the ukrainians is
unfortunate uh but they are supportive
of russia saying that what they call the
western supremacy in a way needs to be
challenged and what russia is doing is
well within its rights to do so but at
the same time there is a very vocal
lobby of public here in india who are
very vocally and openly critical of the
invasion and not only of the invasion
but of the indian government's
diplomatic response saying that there's
no need to walk the tight rope that
india has been doing
so
public opinion being one thing when ira
what about
the business interests there are indian
companies willing to join the west in
moving away from russia economically or
do they now see a chance to establish a
foothold in the russian market
well if we talk about the responses from
the business industries of course it has
not been as enthusiastic and severing
its ties as we can see in the west
although two big companies have
announced starting their business with
russia one of them is infosys which is a
software giant the other is an indian
multinational steel making company
called tata steel both of them have
joined a handful of indian companies who
have announced severing of ties with
russia but as you just said this is also
opening up an opportunity for other
indian companies to as you said gaining
a foothold in the russian market and
basically taking advantage of the vacuum
that has been created as other
global companies are making their way
out of russia so that of course is
happening but that of course is not an
easy proposition and at the same time
after being shunned uh by the u.s and
the european union there is a supply hit
in russia as well and it is looking
towards india to uh basically match some
of those uh supply hits especially when
it comes to pharmaceuticals and textiles
and agriculture
richard walker international
correspondent back in here in berlin um
we've heard that the indian european
relations are under strain right now do
you think this visit uh will
help to bridge this the rift if you will
well yeah i mean i think it
it's not necessarily something that we
can talk of as a massive rift because
you're not going to hear a huge amount
of really open criticism
from the german side of india i think
you see both the europeans and the
americans
being very cautious in criticizing india
we just heard in the report there uh
foreign minister jay shankar what his
response was when he talked about well
guess what things have been going on in
asia in recent years uh europe perhaps
wasn't as interested in us then as it
should have been but certainly you hear
a lot from german politicians of trying
to sort of pull india in rather than
push it away to try to draw it into uh
into closer ties with the west through
all of these agreements and try to kind
of coax it in a direction that they
would like to see but there is one other
elephant in the room here and that is
the current political situation within
india manira can of course talk more
about that but uh there is a sense and i
was in india last week reporting there's
a sense of a really agitated environment
in india's society
narendra modi's hindu nationalist
government is accused of trampling on
the rights of the muslim minority there
there have been uh
incidents of hate demolitions of of
muslim homes and businesses
a really quite febrile atmosphere and
this is another thing which is which is
certainly causing concern in germany
that they want to cooperate with the
democratic india but they're one
worrying about what direction democratic
india is actually taking
dws chief international editor richard
walker there and our correspondent maria
chowri in delhi thank you both
germany is one of india's top 10 global
trading partners
more than 1700 german companies are
present there accounting for about four
hundred thousand jobs in the indian
labor market
i'm joined now by amrita narlikar she's
president of the giga institute in
hamburg i'm rita thank you for joining
us you've written that the eu and india
are natural allies and yet trade
relations between the two have been
difficult in recent years why is that
uh hi stephen great to see you
so um yes what i've written is that the
eu and india are even though they should
be natural allies they are involved in a
rather clumsy tangle
and there are several reasons for this
a big one is that the eu tends to place
a lot of emphasis on business and
development relations with india
and this isn't these are issues that
india too is interested in promoting
especially under the business and growth
oriented modi government but the eu then
very swiftly goes down
a cul-de-sac of the narrowly defined
values
of social and environmental standards
whenever the fta is discussed
and the tone of these discussions can
come across
as if the europeans are preaching to
their indian counterparts
on the importance of liberal values
and neither the content nor the tone of
these discussions are useful
for winning trust especially when
negotiating with an ancient civilization
like in
well to play devil's advocate here these
big trade packages are very complicated
to get approved by all the countries in
the eu and there often is a focus on
social and environmental uh the
practices
of the trade partner isn't it likely
that countries like france like germany
like belgium are going to look at those
issues when it comes to a trade package
with india and that could be a problem
to do one of these overarching packages
well what i would emphasize is that the
overarching packages are important and
needed
the notion of values however needs to be
expanded
to include
environmental standards social standards
but also think about geo strategic
questions questions of security
and macro level values which include
democracy liberalism pluralism
uh these are all values that india
shares with the european union the
problem is that trade is regarded quite
narrowly um by the eu by the commission
and it and that is why we get this
emphasis much more on the narrower
uh labor and environmental standards
rather than bigger questions of
democracy pluralism
in the sense is it likely that the war
in ukraine will complicate things
between the two sides or could it
actually represent an opportunity
if the war uh the russian invasion of
ukraine could uh
it could be a really important trigger
for deepening the cooperation between eu
and india and also germany and india
um so on the one hand you could keep
trying to point the finger at india for
not taking a strong stance in favor of
democratic ukraine
and this will not help eu india or in or
indo-german cooperation but in fact what
the what
what the war has shown germany and
europe
is the risks of over dependence on
russia
india also has a difficult neighbor in
its region china
and let's not forget the no limits
partnership announced by russia and
china earlier this year so there is an
authoritarian advance happening on the
borders of the eu and happening on the
borders of india
and
so this is an amazingly important
opportunity and necessity for both india
and germany to be building secure supply
chains for eu and india to be building
secure supply chains
especially in strategically important
sectors like 5g technology medical
supplies
infrastructure
also dual use technology
all right i'm rita narlikar's president
of the giga institute in hamburg talking
about india eu trade relations i'm rita
thank you very much